♪ [music] ♪
Give me one minute and I'll show you
how Data Catalog can empower you
to better discover, understand,
and manage all of your data assets.
Data Catalog
is Google Cloud's highly scalable
data discovery and metadata
management service.
Data Catalog provides you
with a simple-to-use search interface
for data discovery and an API
for programmatic access
and building custom applications.
It's powered by the same
Google search technology
that supports popular Google services
like Drive and Gmail.
And it's fully managed
for effortless setup
with no additional
infrastructure to manage.
With Data Catalog,
you create tag templates
that let you tag your data assets
with structured tags.
Structured tags let you capture
any complex business metadata,
like the person responsible
for that data asset,
data classification, retention policies,
or whether the data contains sensitive,
personal, identifiable information.
Speaking of PII,
Data Catalog has built-in
Cloud Data Loss Prevention integration
so that it can detect and tag
your sensitive data automatically.
Do your data assets exist across
a lot of different systems?
Data Catalog not only supports
Google Cloud data sources,
but also third-party ones
via open-source connectors.
With these integrations,
you'll be able to search
all your business metadata
and receive one unified view
no matter where your data resides.
Next time you're looking for a way
to manage all of your data assets,
take a minute and check out Data Catalog.
Find out more
at cloud.google.com/data-catalog
♪ [music] ♪